Hey guys Justin I was telling myself to see you gotta stop you gotta cut down on the iPhone videos beginning
You got a new iPhone and everybody knows that but the new a Century City Apple store
Just opened up the day at the iPhone 10 came out
So it's driving past and I decided that I need to come and check it out. I came here to this Apple store
I think it waits in line for an iPad at some point I
Got too, that's what I'm getting I'm getting the pink one
Not really sure where it's at this is all new, but they just recently reopened up this mall so everything is brand new
I've never seen you
So where's the Apple Store
Here it is I didn't even recognize a because there's no big Apple logo anywhere
The only Apple logo is over here that I could see which is kind of crazy because it's super bright that I really didn't even
See it
OK, I push my iPhone now because this camera just died so
Welcome to the life of vlogging behind me is the new Apple Store. Let's get it
Exposed so, there it is. there's the Apple logo?
Right there
It's so quiet in here this reminds me a lot of the one in New York that they have with this huge screen
This is awesome, and they have like a little needed Apple area you can sit right here and learn and hang out
I want to see something on this screen
Look at this. We're doing a live art with Simon. I've got Rowan a puzzle
Stay have the apple cases opened up this like, I know, I cannot believe haven't get it these
How do I buy them it's so crazy
I could figure out how to get a case and only got a do you pull this open and there's right here
It's like magic so the new Apple store is really really nice
But I just got home and I texted Matt and Jenna
I said hey you guys and play call of duty, and Matt says we should all have a LAN party
And I got really excited
I told everybody to come here my internet kind of sucks, but in fact on my xbox
And I'm gonna go we're gonna have nice land part. It's gonna be great. It's the food one of the things
That's a problem though is Matt
Plays mostly on playstation because he's a pro player and most of the pros all play on playstation
They used to play on xbox, but then now they're all on PlayStation which is unfortunate the past two years
I switched back over to PlayStation to play call of duty
And then I realized that I never actually ever play with a pro player, so it really doesn't matter so this year
I'm playing Call Of Duty
Back when Xbox like it doesn't even matter if I have a 4k Xbox or not because I play on really small monitors
It's all about the refresh rate, baby. Let's go
Yes, it does everything is just going swimmingly
Do you see this this is my first smartphone
I'm gonna do a video soon reacting to some of the things that I have on here
I did plug it in and I was pretty shocked future video you might bring this one
So this whole past week has basically been iPhone week, and I have non-stop and shooting and editing videos. It's pretty time-consuming so today
I'm gonna treat myself. We're gonna be playing some games Call Of Duty. He came out a few days ago
These are the best hard drives ever other the samsung solid-state drives. No, I'm pretty vapor flip my switch in here
I might have to bring another bag
One for Jenna, let's see maybe I'll bring one for Matt to
Check out this sweet wine fridge look how much wine I have?
Hmm gonna have to work on the wine selection one of Jenna's friends and neighbors was moving out
And they couldn't fit their wine fridge in the truck to take it with him
So I was like I'll take that off your hands. I gotcha I got you
I
Got line. I don't have much. Okay. We gotta go we gotta go
I'm picking up some goodies for our land party Jenna said to get popcorn these though
Classic salted sounds good great
And it get settle on a line this one right here has a little pig on it, so it's got to be good
HQ Trivia Time Genuine
Scott's polishing his hair!
What are you doing?
Polishing  my hair
Somebody required reading
What!?
HQ trivia
Here's iJustine
As your flow coat
Not sponsored
No! You are shooting!
Gimme a shut up, Scott
That's all I want
I want you shut up so much
Oh I seem say you now
Painting
Yup
Hundred percent
He's getting the art
I always learned art
No one everyone goes... the art with me
I forgot, I was vlogging too so it's 12:47
We played a lot of Call Of Duty, ate a lot of snacks
Not really sure if the LAN party was a success. I think it wasn't mean and Jenna play, Ed was working
Matt sort of late eats a cupcake drink soda and had great stories and
Conversational exchanges we had a great time we did we do
good dialogue, or great dialogue
I could say we had great dialogue. No
Yeah, we got a we got to walk the dog, and I got to go home because I've got a lot of stuff to pack
up
Eat your cupcake at I'm so upset
Why is it either right now? I'm stream. I mean on film. It's okay
You don't have to just you know you've long, and I mean I mean well. I'm filming that's my breakfast
I'm talking that was really sassy, so yes, Matt. I'm vlogging, I'm so sleepy
Look at this
I'm watching the video launched last night
Was just watching Matt's video that we fell into last night before we had our wonderful LAN party today
I kind of took the day off because last week it was insane with iPhone week
I basically didn't sleep at all for a week
I was shooting and editing just pretty much non-stop trying to get content out for you guys about the iPhone cuz obviously the iPhone for me
Is like the one time of year I guess this year. We were graced with two times a year yesterday
I went to Century City the new mall, and I was like guys you gotta go to this mall it looks great
It's awesome so today. We're going back so this vlog is going to pick up basically where this vlog started
We're going back to the mall. This is Maddie for anybody who may be new here
He's my sweet pup we rescued him two years ago can let me have this one. Give me this
Sit
Good sit. so we're gonna see movie Matt. You know comes here to pick me up, and he's like okay you're driving
I'm like, "Wait, what?" Just let me drive you I promise everywhere. Why don't you trust me to drive your car?
Um no no no. But check out one for each. I think should you guys it, but I'm really excited about it
Okay, hey take a look at how much wine I have in there?
Looks good, though
Probably just put bottles of water. That's actually a great idea quick. They'd be a nice temperature cuz it's not too cold okay
Let's go to the theater. I guess I'm driving dinner. Do you want me to drive your mom? Yeah?
Just back into a hole that wasn't
I'm actually whole forward it in the hole now
Get the story straight!
Jenna drove. she wanted you guys the update and Matt in the back seat because... yelling yelling about her. She's not yelling
Yelling at the driver, "Who?!"
Today's Justine is so goofy
It not have bright goofy.
Now I'm trying to park near the elevator.
You need park suit teachcally because then I'm campfiring in a car
Sometimes they don't make sense yeah, get out don't make sense in your head. Yeah, cuz my brain is developing
I'm I can see this at night because when I was here yesterday
It was really bright, and you didn't actually exceed the full hook of the new Apple story
It looks so much better at night. Look at it. Oh, yeah, this looks good
This just opened up on November 3rd. This is the first day what I love that activity
Let's close the ring
Okay
Do you have apple care?
I did get up. Okay have to get it oh
He isn't carrying anything that you hope for it is going to be when I have my first accident yep great
Sorry, all right there. It is. That's uh two trips the Apple store in
Two days that's on a call
Jenna got our AppleCare now we need to find some food potentially do a little bit of shopping
I think you're good. I hit my limit for spending but our movie starts at 7:00. Oh we don't much time
the mall
the mall the mall
mall the mall
Tango does the Macarena definitely is not experience is definitely not
We just got home from seeing Thor and Matt was saying man
I really wish that I had some new Apple watch bands well guess what?
I have a bunch of watch bands for you because I switched to the 38 and math has the 42 do with em take a
Look and see what I got oh
God wait you were not kidding. Yeah, okay? What color would you like I was looking for a darker color, okay?
Well, let's see what you getting have.  Umm... Yeah, all bright colors. I'm sorry. Here you go. Um, Thanks for watching guys
They showed us a posted vlog cuz it's been awesome say I have actually posted a vlog vlog
I've been posting a ton of iPhone videos as you guys know
A bunch of cooking videos
What's up? That part of water here, it's so easy you just see this little button right here push that in a little bit and then
That's it
It's pretty exciting. Thanks, Justine. You're welcome. I'm glad someone's getting use of them. Wow this is great. Hey, man
Here's com' in, com' on  You can put your hand in it, then. You should put your hand underneath his toys
He's instant really like.
Yes